I don't have the map to the future I'm
sorry to report I wish I did I know I
know that was the only way I got this
gig but I left the map in my other suit
III think you can say a couple things
with relative certainty not about
outcomes but about process number one
one of my rules is we're moving from an
either-or pass to a both/and future and
i genuinely believe some way or another
we will have newspapers and journalism
and professional journalists people who
subscribe to the rules of journalism
fact-checking and balanced reporting an
attempt to get both sides of a story an
attempt to do deep gigs of investigative
journalism I don't see any reason to
believe that's gonna disappear it may
change it may morph it may be under
invested in it may come from different
places that it comes right now I think
that's a deep social need secondly
there's a deep human need and the deep
human need is for participation
engagement checking in connecting that's
the technological revolution it makes it
possible for all of us to talk to each
other all the time
we may get overloaded it may be too much
Ted Leavitt used to say anything in
excess is a poison we may have to dial
it down but it is true that the notion
that you know the there is a private
preserve for journalists and the rest of
us are consumers is completely false it
is it goes against Megan Smith's rules
and it doesn't work so journalists have
to let go of the notion that they are
the high priests of reporting and truth
they're really valuable they do what
they do really well and we need them we
also have this public dialogue
marketplace of of interaction and
discourse and personal reflection or or
just absolute time-wasting but people
want to do that the human animal wants
to get up in the morning and look around
and talk about the weather how their
team did how they feel what they did
last night that they shouldn't have done
I a couple years ago I took a trip to
Tanzania and it was a safari by day and
a kind of a men's group by night sitting
around the fire and there was a tribe we
spent a lot of time with called the
hodza B and the hodza B are for the last
70,000 years they've been hunting and
gathering in Tanzania and they still do
it and what I observed was hilarious the
men in the tribe who were who were with
us on this Safari this adventure at
night when we'd go into our tents and go
to bed they would get in a little pile
near the fire and they would get really
close like a like a puppy pile and go to
sleep and then couple hours later one of
them would move and wake up the whole
group and they'd hear people coughing
and and and lighting up smokes and and
moving around and checking in with each
other and then the group would quiet
down and they'd go back to sleep a
couple hours later somebody would coughs
somebody would roll over all of a sudden
the tribe is talking to each other
everybody here everybody okay that is
human behavior and it's primal you know
you know you don't think of it as
journalism but it's a form of journalism
everybody checking in you okay yeah I'm
okay here you want a smoke yeah okay
everybody okay
all right go back to sleep get up in the
morning all right the weather's not so
good where we gonna hunt today I mean
these are guys going out with poison
arrows and bows to bring back food so
it's pretty elemental but they still
check in that's what we're doing you
know you may may not say that's
journalism
it may simply be community interaction
but we need both we need the gossip and
we need the deep digging in the news and
the technology exists to do both the
problem is that the old business model
of journalism is broken not journalism
the business model so we have to detach
the business model from the need for
that kind of reporting analysis really
professional stuff reinvent a business
model that gets us what we need in that
zone without somehow somehow disputing
the value of all of us tribal people
checking in with each other to make sure
we're still ok and we're ready to go
hunting for the day they're not it's not
an either/or choice and we have to make
peace so that they can live with each
other
fast company is doing well and my hat is
off to Bob safety and who just won the
editor of the Year award and the
magazine is you know alive and well and
doing good stuff and when when my hands
completely off of it so I don't have any
pride in authorship there I I think it
comes you know it it gets back again to
nouns and verbs magazines aren't
interesting to me magazine is
interesting and the magazines that are
doing magazine are doing well in my
month what does that actually mean well
as a reader as a consumer of information
as a curious human being when I pick up
a magazine I'm not looking for
information information is a commodity
just like news is a commodity what I'm
looking for is a performance I'm looking
for a take on the world I'm looking for
a point of view one of the rules in
rules of thumb is the notion that
content isn't king context is king and
the point is that there is that content
is a commodity it's just something you
push through a pipe i I might I might or
might not buy it but I certainly am NOT
going to pay top dollar for it and I'm
not gonna affiliate with it I'm not
going to join the content community but
if you've got a point of view if you
make sense of the world in a distinctive
way if you've got an argument you want
to advance and engage me in I'm
interested in that I may not agree with
you but boy your mind is active and
alert and alive on the page and that's
something that's worth money
so magazine to me is the art of taking a
position staking out a territory
defining a take on the world bringing
your skills of storytelling and
performance to an audience or a
participating audience that wants to
engage actively in a dialogue that's
alive and well
and the publications that do that are
the ones that are flourishing and the
ones that are dwindling really bought
into I think a kind of a Darwinian dead
end and that is it's enough to collect
information and slam it between covers
and now we're you know we're we're
authoritative or were the news of the
week the news of the week is very weak
and it isn't going to survive